à 15 ans benoît de l'ambition beaucoup
d'ambition sally futur il la reine en
agriculteur ou plutôt en éleveurs car il
adore les vaches
depuis quelques années il a intégré la
classe ulis du collège du 12e kilomètre
du tampon ce matin ce collégien studieux
les visant devoir de maths avec son
accompagnatrice valérie dans quel sens
faire partir 22 gauche comme moi ça y
est voilà tu attends lice
maintenant on va chercher y 2 voilà je
suis en train de réviser pour une
ablation de maths ou tout à l'heure
c'est un élève très sage très studieux
donc je mangeais ritaine siens il veut
apprendre donc le dfe le défaut de
benoît je dirais c'est que ici jamais
dire non
il est toujours prêt à prendre toujours
motivés même prêt est fatigué il va il
va donner à 100% depuis l'année dernière
depuis haute la mécanique exactement
travailler pour réussir mais surtout
travailler autrement pour ces jeunes qui
ne peuvent pas suivre un cursus scolaire
classique
nous sommes ici dans la classe ulis
unité localisée pour l'inclusion
scolaire qui accueille des enfants en
situation de handicap
ici chacun va à son rythme soutenu par
des accompagnatrices qui ont chacune en
élève dédié aux plusieurs élèves selon
les besoins de l'unité oui j'aime bien
ce que je fais c'est qu'elle est très
bien été notifiée pour lui
que je le suis en ulis et je pars en
inclusion avec les benoît qui se partage
entre les cours spécifiques de la classe
ulis et des cours avec les autres
collégiens
il rejoint aussi son professeur de
mathématiques pour le devoir du jour
pour cette dernière benoît est un élève
comme les autres alors là celui là le
tableau il se fait le graphique comme et
les points ici la faire ici il faudra
compléter avec les valeurs et mettre le
détail des calculs par contre sur cette
feuille d spécifié je vois pas de
différence avec benoît en fait un il est
totalement intégrée dans la classe il
fait partie entière de la classe et ça
pose absolument aucun problème il n'y a
pas un regard particulier des élèves sur
benoît donc ça c'est vraiment très bien
aussi
ça permet justement d'intégrer les
élèves dans une classe je dirais entre
guillemets normal et puis il s'est
totalement intégrée justement à cette
classe et il travaille très très bien et
je pense que c'est un apport pour lui
quoi c'est vraiment très très positif
pour cette élève à vous avec corinne que
marguerite fait ses devoirs
elles l'accompagnent également dans la
classe pour ses autres courts participé
à la réussite de ses élèves est une
fierté pour marguerite qui aime son
métier avec les élèves d'ulis je me
jeunes occupent un peu tous les élèves
vous regarde qui a quoi comme travail à
faire les devoirs revenus assure un
cours qui n'ont pas compris quand ils
arrivent dans la classe après le
courroux fait toujours on leur demande
toujours
s'ils l'ont bien compris j'aime la
proximité avec les élèves en difficulté
les aider à avancer et voir au bout
qu'ils soient capables de travailler
sont plaints de comment ça ils vont vite
travailler ils ont envie de réussir
et ça ça fait plaisir la fin de l'année
de voir que les ont bien travaillé qui
veulent réussir chaque handicapé
particulier et pour chaque enfant on
trouve des chemins d adaptation
particulière donc pour chaque enfant on
trouve un chemin particulier autres
autre particularité de notre travail
c'est qu'on fait du lien entre les
parents
la vie scolaire les profs et madame et f
qui est le professeur de l'ulis puisque
nous en circule beaucoup on voit
beaucoup de monde et donc après les sens
de notre mission c'est que les enfants
ils soient bien à l'école c'est très
enrichissant fait je vais me sens utile
d'aider les jeunes en difficulté on les
a on apporte une aide de technique on là
où ils peuvent pas réussir en fait
prendre des notes
les accompagner dans les actes de la vie
quotidienne on se sent utile qu'on se
dit qu'il ya une évolution et que l est
et elle avance de l'autre côté le
professeur et coordonnateur marie-france
et eve distille les informations d'une
manière plus compréhensible pour ces
jeunes en situation de handicap une
pédagogie différente pour les aider à
comprendre les difficultés de la langue
française
non pas demain on rit frais et nombre de
morts quand on utilise ne pas on dit le
la phrase contraire contraire de la
france alors qu'il n'a pas la même car
un grand mur de pierre entoure le
potager un grand mur de pierre potager
wilfried est très attentif et répond à
toutes les questions
mais ce jeune garçon de 12 ans et demi
n'aime pas l'école il préférerait jouer
avec ses camarades bien devant l'école
même pas travail des enfants différents
dans un milieu ordinaire même manière
d'apprendre à l'autre la tolérance
accepter les différences pour mieux
s'enrichir
une leçon de vie qui fonctionne très
bien dans cet établissement scolaire
sont indifférents que nous mais plutôt
que c'est bien et toi comment ça se
passe mais que ben c'est génial on joue
avait parfois on plaisant et parfois on
me demande des questions
sur nous qui sont normales et j'essaye
de les expliquer ma façon basse et des
personnes comme nous et il faut les
accepter tels qu'ils sont ils sont
autant aussi gentil cno pense qu'ils
sont différents
ben non justement ils sont pas
différents ils sont vraiment ils sont
comme nous qu'ils aiment bien parce
qu'ils sont sympas cette classe ulis de
niveau iv concerne des élèves présentant
n'importe quel handicap
c'est pourquoi le collège est totalement
accessible aux personnes à mobilité
réduite
pour benoît wilfried pauline et les
autres la classe ulis est une chance
celle de réussir leur vie mais surtout
de changer le regard des autres sur le
handicap